who did you grow up listening to who
would you consider to be like your main
influences when it comes to just rapping
and being an artist
oh [ __ ] oh I came up on Chief Keef
yeah when Chief Keef came out 2012 my
whole life changed for the better like I
just was a different person like he hit
the city hit the city of Jacksonville
hard like real hard right and I ain't
saying like because you know you got
older people in Jacksonville that was
like grown he came out right but I'm
saying like for my age range or people
that's like in a 23 24 yeah and she keep
it hard everybody became a Sosa in the
city like everybody was putting Sosa
behind their name everybody wanted to
lock the hell up like everybody when you
see a [ __ ] with the trash
this dress in his face you can't see his
face you feel me everybody wanted to
start drinking lean everybody wanted to
start Ranch religion like that [ __ ] just
changed the city Jesus I mean yeah I
mean I think you know Chief Keef is one
of the most influential rappers ever
I think when it comes to the last
probably 15 years
he's probably
at least the last decade no the last
decade he's number one for sure it's
like him or future
for sure but I think anytime I talk to
an artist like they always say Chief
Keef oh no though because like
me when I was growing up I had like I
was around my big brothers and John like
eat my bit right my family member right
Brothers but literal Brothers yeah like
they was on future hard like they what
got me on to Future yeah so around that
time like
sonically you hear future in everybody
now
like sonically sort of a sense you kind
of hear hints of future or Thug and
everybody now sort of a sense in terms
of not everybody but when you hear the
artists who do like heavily do melodic
[ __ ] you hear future and post Malone you
hear future and I might go on and on and
on like his influence is vast in terms
of just like the style of music whereas
I Feel Like Chief kee's influence on
just the internet the way people were
dressing obviously the drill [ __ ] which
went over to the UK came back went to
New York went to Jacksonville it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah